we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is a voicemail
inquiring about exactly the scenario
that i outlined earlier for election day
and election week take a listen to this
hola david
tomas from chile here i'm thinking the
most likely scenario on election night
is that trump will declare victory
because
most republicans will vote in person and
most of their votes will have been
counted by that
by that point uh i'm thinking democrats
will have their votes
counted in bases another weeks after and
trump will call fraud potentially
leading to some violence how how can we
even
prepare for something like that
so listen let me get to the preparation
in a second but yes what tomas is
describing here
is the red mirage hypothesis the red
mirage hypothesis will be
since we know that we're going to have
um
so so the people planning to vote in
person are mostly trump people
and the people planning to vote absentee
are mostly biden people now the exact
proportions will determine whether this
happens but it is a completely plausible
scenario
that trump seems to eke out some victory
on election night
claims victory and then his absentee
ballots continue to be counted i don't
think it will take weeks but it
certainly could take five days
the lead for trump shrinks shrinks
shrinks until ultimately joe biden takes
an electoral lead
and you were completely correct tomas
that that
is a scenario ripe for real world
violence and so the question about how
to be prepared for it
is twofold first of all police
departments
and national law enforcement federal law
enforcement
need to take seriously the possibility
of not
protests of overwhelmingly unarmed
individuals
but angry weaponized trumpists
with firearms taking to the streets
that's a law enforcement question
the political question is we know
because trump uh has said that they're
going to do this and people around trump
have said they've got an army of lawyers
ready to go
we know that if this scenario happens if
trump seems to be ahead on election
night
with a lot of absentee ballots still to
be counted
immediately they are going to file
lawsuits to try to stop the absentee
ballots from being counted they are
going to try to say
they've got to be in by by midnight
election day or they've got to be in by
the next day but you can't just keep
counting absentee ballots
whether they will get away with it i
don't know but democrats
and joe biden's campaign need to have a
proactive plan for how they are going to
fight that in court now unfortunately
when trump brags he's put in place
is it 200 something 300 judges at this
point
it may be some of those judges who end
up
deciding in some states do the
absentee ballots continue to be counted
or not so it is a very
serious scenario and i don't know if
democrats are going to be prepared if
history is an indicator
democrats may well not be prepared for
that and that's very very scary
on the bonus show today we are going to
talk about the pandemic remaining the
top issue for voters going into november
and what effect that is likely to have
depending on what happens with the virus
in the next eight weeks
we're also going to talk about calls to
end open carry of firearms
period as an institution and lastly
jacob blake's father is now receiving
death threats
jacob blake of course is the young man
who is now paralyzed
after being shot in kenosha wisconsin
and now his father is the one receiving
death threats
it's unconscionable and we will talk
about all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show
become a member get instant access at
joinpakman.com